Oh what let me do my friggin intro where
is it you got a jet [ __ ] those
creatures are everywhere
hey bro I'm not your mother [ __ ] talk
[ __ ] you waiting for
I don't know got it
someone talking to me I don't know it
[ __ ] you waiting for
hey bro Adam okay I am coming
I didn't just don't know where I'm
supposed to go did I go backwards oh
heck you waiting for dick bro down to
print whoa I jumped like a boss we got a
jet [ __ ] those creatures
everywhere okay wait
there you are brah yeah you scared me
the last episode man all right we got a
whoa did you hear that breathing torque
you liked it yeah dad's awesome man
where where where whoa I told you deal
with that one oh look at this fire
extinguisher oh don't talk
so I'm reloading brah douche I gotta go
into power mode there we go how about
activate
[Applause]
power mode you activate all right you
like that card it doesn't even care he's
like a pretty Norma
oh come on another one what the [ __ ]
alright power mode I can't go in power
mode
don't do something please crazy
fire Americans
oh now I'm here
[Music]
[Applause]
all right we're good there yeah we're
good
I hear someone
come on
oh you better cross oh stop doing your
power
that's why I'm talking to anyone house
huh
want a tango when I meet okay okay let's
go let's go let's go let's go how do I
climb outta here we go damn this game is
[ __ ] crazy
holy [ __ ] I [ __ ] the bricks this way to
bust out yep yes where did it go though
talk
I mean breath talk we got to get out of
this [ __ ] right come on talk we
got to get out of this [ __ ] okay
bro come on talk we got to get out of
this I'm right [ __ ] here way out
through this cell block
it's some bad [ __ ] in there man [ __ ]
up juju [ __ ] up you just no other way
come on Turk I think I'll let you go
first brah thanks fine Targa's not a
brother bro
i'll tell you about president Walker man
we gotta watch out those [ __ ] cutters
are everywhere in here but this is the
only way to go man if we gonna bounce up
out of this [ __ ] hole
I agree brah damn new coming back in
here with a bad idea to a machine not me
I think you better take point lead us
through this [ __ ] are you paying
is it buzzing use it all right sighs
whoa what the [ __ ] was that
[Applause]
Oh locker room leaves a naked lady hey
there's no naked first like what they
did to Byron Byron goddamn looks like
these things kill their own to
[ __ ] yeah I found the gap feel so naked
man I won't be able to smoke them like
you can't but I got your back
all right brother let's go in here look
at here
penetration look do you see this torque
keep seeing it oh my god it's not racist
because Wow okay let's click that hey
hey whoa whoa what that nice I hope I
get to meet him
all right nothing to fear a finger
painting I love fingered me
alrights going here ah hey it in there
SEC you know what I just realized
nothing only brother I ever heard of who
actually made it out of habit before
their bid was up [ __ ] the parole board
man beat him
yeah good for you bad [ __ ] man T block I
like keep dope better keep our heads up
in here there's no telling where those
Jim freaks out I knew skinny
[ __ ] once spend all his days
mainline in the China wife wound up so
cooked he couldn't tell you his own name
they're really freaking reminds me of
him
mainland well you know you shouldn't
swear that man hey how you then say
you're just gonna kill me I don't know
hey look lady you pirate
yeah today she doesn't know Oh with them
what was that ah bro bro then whoa whoa
let up rhetoric I'm sorry bro rubber I
whoa Oh mom over here I'm back let's
right there whoa
that's right
good stuff [ __ ] no talk you're shooting
at me house mantra I'm [ __ ] out of
here hey lady I felt trapped II I just
had to get out okay first I didn't want
conjugal visits I just wasn't ready to
give up my own life my chance at a
career
I regret both times live team you've got
to be strong to be free oh [ __ ] no not
this [ __ ] again always with my wife
[Applause]
spiders
holy [ __ ]
like a better reason yoga subscribe to
coverage today and I'll see you next
episode ever make sales and Ruth how you
wanna play games
I know karate i speaking
[Music]